so we have been working this money on
the illicit trade council where I am a
member and we had discussed very very
exciting things in terms of how to
define some of the objectives and the
problems so one of the things we look
into is how technology which is the area
working with can solve some of the
issues related to illicit trade for
instance one concrete example is
providing a strong authentication of
objects so you can trace them over the
internet issues related to
counterfeiting and how the using new
technologies and innovation can help to
reduce the number of counterfeit
products the Internet has now fifty
percent of the products of Internet are
fake is one trillion dollar economy
which represents five percent of the
global trade so obviously finding an
urgent solution around the country
fitting issue is essential for the work
of this or a specific council